donc monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur speed runners un rejet
qui fait énormément parler du lancement
parce qu'il est vraiment fun je pense
que vous connaissez étant donné qu'il ya
plein de youtube heures qu'ont déjà fait
des vidéos dessus mais pour ceux qui
connaissent pas les règles en 10
secondes
c'est tout con c'est juste une course
sauf que l'écran va suivre le joueur qui
est en tête ce qui fait que c'était trop
à la bourre et que tu sortes de l'écran
bah t'as perdu
bien évidemment votre majesté ya
quelques petits objets que tu peux
ramasser tout vous dire qui monte la
course qui vous laisse les découvrir en
vidéo j'espère que ça vous plaira bon
visionnage
vas-y dégager la ta mère est allée tard
tu as tu peur ici
donc là c'est le bluetooth cours à base
c'est trois roquettes en fait ciao on me
rassemble ricains apparemment ça n'a pas
trop marché l'éveil des cadeaux plus
apparemment
when you boys boys boys boys ah mais oui
c'est un tricheur le combo est riche il
à mbouda à
je rattrape faut que je n'avais pas plus
car à jamais ma puissance ok j'étais
mort mais les mecs médiévale est ce que
je peux battre la whey c'est quoi ouais
matin d'ailleurs noms sont fourbes cpie
cas ils attendent comme savait quoi et
cela sans que ça fait un croche-patte
moines allez je vous laisse toucher
l'eau d'où la mise mais à tous qu égaux
tu fais quoi avec jean loup tient ferme
ta gueule aujourd'hui un succès vous
allez me suis un succès joué une heure
avec un cheat et passe à lui cassant
l'encontre oui
vas-y je suis vers quoi non c'est oui
alors de grâce à une [ __ ] qui cache tout
bête alors mickaël nativel il a déjà
deux fois oui je sais j'ai fait ce que
je te vois ça s'appelle la pâte son
deuxième but arrive trop le seul
ok j'avais utilisé sur ce grave
c'est pas la langue qu'on a fait 600
milliards de fois ci c'était bien que je
suis l'ami de cajou et même vu coincer
un pixel de mon écran on voit les seuls
sur des points sur ce match là gazon
équivoque aller mais c'est qu'on voit là
comme ça c'est le rebord la trahison du
rebord elle était là elle était fatal à
jean louis attention du catch à mourir a
établi un disque ait surprise à puce
[ __ ] j'suis pas si presse non tu sors
la défaite la nique à un [ __ ] ma pas
un croche-patte avant que je le fasse
mais bon c'est pas moi ils ont laissé
montre
faire des combats de l'algue offert sa
technique
non non alors mais kyle à pied regardez
regardez technique de merde mais non
qu'est ce que je suis qu est ce que j
attendais tiens elle est super chaud
attend d'un flagship la can put un
carton plein non on regarde où je suis
tricheur
tu fais quoi
j'ai envie de pleurer j'arrête pour
essayer alors vous êtes sa place
non je ne parlerai pas de l'e3 là je
pleure
le pourquoi moi ah non je vais te
raconter comme ça fait plus tricher en
herbe un petit vieux van damme iaa mais
ton ami ah ouais j'aime bien cette map
alors qui marque qui meurt dès le début
moi moi moi c'est moi c'est moi je
suppose la forme d'art à l'uqar au
[ __ ] tu perds encore de consensus
bonne journée
mais non mais non
le laser le laser est accordée au
président c'était quoi ce magasin de la
vidéo
la dernière les mecs c'est la dernière
non pourquoi ça ça fait deux mois n'ont
gagné pour la défaite oui avec alan penn
dernières années derrière et jamais vu
en premier lieu les 6 meilleurs premiers
je te dis bon tant pis pour toi j'ai ouï
à l'école voisine dernièrement dernière
non non non non non ce serait bien non
stop
derrière on a burning up j'espère dès
pas calculé pour la légion c'est déjà la
fin de cette petite vidéo sur speed run
alors j'espère que ça vous aura plu
c'est ce cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
ça me fera plaisir en tout cas moi comme
vous avez pu voir ça m'a plutôt fait
rire quand je vais pas leur mentir non
non je vous dis à bientôt dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat au monde
pis son accord
et
c'est